vous parliez de l'Iran l'Iran qui a
appelé hier à rompre tout lien avec
Israël et qui a appelé au boycott de ses
produits l'Iran veut s'imposer comme le
champion de la cause palestinienne
aujourd'hui pas seulement de la cause
palestinienne oui mais de l'ensemble
exercer l'hégémonie sur le monde arabe
si vous voulez depuis un certain nombre
d'années déjà le la rivalité entre chiit
et sunnit est très importante notamment
depuis la révolution iranienne 1979 où
romainie est imposé comme une sorte de
champion tiermondiste de la cause arabe
palestinienne alors qu'il n'est ni arabe
ni sunnite et on a vu au cours des 40 50
dernières années des basculements de
l'hégémonie vous voyez quand romainie
fait la Fati du 14 février 1989 contre
Salman rougedi il tire le tapis sous les
pieds des sunnites qui viennent de
chasser l'Armée rouge d'Afghanistan le
départ l'Armée Rouge et le lendemain on
ne le voit pas et il il gagne la guerre
Médi
le 11 septembre 2001 c'est la réponse si
j'ose dire du berger sunnite à la berger
archéite et c'est Ben Laden avec
l'attaque spectaculaire
sur sur les tours jumelles et sur le
Pentagone qui gagne la guerre médiatique
le 7 octobre 2023 de nouveau c'est un
enjeu de guerre médiatique
exceptionnelle puisque c'est une sorte
de 11 septembre pour Israël c'est-à-dire
qu'on expose que
Israël invincible comme l' l'Amérique
invincible ne sont que des géants des
colosses au pied d'argile pour reprendre
la métaphore biblique et là simplement
c'est un parti sunnite les Frères
musulmans mais les Frères musulmans
n'ont jamais été comme les salafistes
des antichiites primaires au contraire
la révolution islamique en Iran a été
nourrie de la lecture des Frères
musulmans et quand la République
islamique a eu le pouvoir ils ont fait
très rapidement émettre un timbre poste
à l'image de SAED le penseur de
l'islamisme radical frère musulman
supplicié par Nasser en Égypte en 66
vous voyez et donc tout ça ça a permis
aujourd'hui à l'Iran en
instrumentalisant le à l'Iran chiite en
instrumentalisant le Hamas arabe et
sunnit de se d'apparaître c'est ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire comme le
héros aut os de la résistance l' la
résistance et l'un des choses qui le
montre aujourd'hui c'est la visite
qui vient de se produire du ministre
iranien des Affaires étrangères monsieur
abdolahan qui a fait une conférence de
presse commune avec son homologue turc
monsieur Fidan l'ancien patron du
renseignement et qui ont d'une certaine
manière construit une sorte de front qui
vise à l'hégémonie sur le monde musulman
contre l'Arabie Saoudite il faut bien
voir que l'Arabie Saoudite est visée
directement par ses affaires n'oubliez
pas que l'attentat enfin la la radia
monstrueuse du 7 octobre a lieu juste
après que deux ministres israéliens ont
été reçus en Arabie Saoudite de quoi
avaient peur les Iraniens que par
exemple les Israéliens fournissent si
accord il y avait s'ils allaient plus
loin le un dô de fer par exemple à
l'Arabie Saoudite permettant d'éviter
que les routil qui sont aujourd'hui tout
à fait dans l'actualité qui sont
totalement dans la main des Iraniens qui
leur fournissent les armes les missiles
et cetera attaquent euh le territoire
saudien ont déjà
fait